this is a production of Cornell
University
places but before I get started I wanted
to just orient you to what I'm going to
be talking about today and so I will be
talking about the wvu organic farm 15
years of research and education and
that's because the organic farm has only
been there for about 15 years so and I
actually was there when the organic farm
got its start these pictures that you
see on this first slide will orient you
to where I am in my presentation so when
I talk about biodegradable pots this
will show up in the corner of the slide
so you know kind of where I'm at so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to talk a
little bit about the marker garden
section of the organic farm I'm going to
next talk a little bit about
biodegradable pots and then a little bit
about mulches organic mulches and then
finish up talking a little bit about
education but before we get started I
would like to kind of introduce myself
to you because i am not necessarily a
big name in horticulture despite that
wonderful introduction so but i am a
belgian native which is kind of
interesting by itself i just became a US
citizen about three months ago so I'm
really excited and proud about that I
had a very classical horticulture
training in Europe in Belgium and so one
to vocational technical high school
studying horticulture so I have a very
practical hands-on background but when I
finished up my undergraduate degree at
Michigan State University it was time
for me to go to graduate school and I
found myself in a molecular biology lab
which was Randy Woodson's lab and that's
where I studied flower senescence and
and when i first started at West
Virginia University I continued doing
some of that work on flower senescence
and there's several papers that can be
found with my name on it that is
actually molecular biology work
including this one in a journal of
experimental botany however when I first
came to W there was the idea of starting
up an organic farm because we did not
have a lot of horticulture faculty it
was only natural for me to get involved
in this project and so I started
actually doing work on the organic farm
specifically in vegetable production and
I had that strong kind of background
that allowed me to kind of go between
these very very different fields so a
little bit more about me I do a lot of
teaching I teach anywhere from
greenhouse management to an introductory
plants and people course garden center
management storage and handling of
horticultural crops herbaceous plant
materials and I guide about three to ten
independent study students every
semester so dead can be doing a number
of different types of projects but so I
do a lot of teaching so let's get
started on organic the W organic farms
so why study organic or sustainability
well first of all one major reason for
that is there's consumer demand and I
have to apologize a little bit for this
slide because that the white lettering
doesn't show up as nice on this picture
as I maybe wanted it to but consumer
demand is one of the main reasons to
study organic we can argue back and
forth about what are the benefits of
organic and if it can feed the world or
not but what we cannot argue with is
that organic has seen an increase in
production and consumption every year
for the last so many years since the
final rule came out in 2002 so on a
personal note why do I study organic
farming and how do i see that relate to
flower senescence even well for me
studying organic is kind of like being
tied with your hands behind your back
and trying to figure out how to get
something done and that to me is what
organic is and so I see it as it so I
see it as a real challenge to actually
produce something organically and
because we don't have their easy and
ready way or ready-made ways to deal
with problems so we have to work with an
assistant and so why do we want to have
an order
antique farm well the wvu organic farm
is unique not maybe not completely
unique but it the whole farm is organic
and it is because we wanted a holistic
approach to organic so the farm Exley
incorporates animals chickens and sheep
agronomic crops and vegetable crop
production so it is a very holistic
approach to farming it's supposed to
mimic a very diversified small farm in
Appalachia that's the idea behind it so
a very holistic approach so what are the
goals of the organic farm it is not the
compare conventional with organic we are
going to just assume that we want to
grow organic that we want to give people
that want to grow organic information so
we are not doing any comparison between
conventional and organic production what
we are interested in is best management
practices in organic and we are also
interested in long-term sustainability
so one of the studies that I'm going to
talk about today is to kind of highlight
the idea of doing long-term work and
what kind of influence or what kind of
impact that can have and then the lastly
is to educate undergraduate students and
graduate students at this facility so
what you're seeing here is the actual
market garden outline or the actual
organic farm outlined in red and in
white is the market garden section of
the farm so to continue talk a little
bit more about organic so what I'm going
to talk about today is the market garden
so I'm not going to talk about agronomic
rob's i'm not going to talk about the
sheep or the chickens i'm just going to
focus in on vegetable production after i
talk a little bit about the long-term
studies that we've got going on in the
market garden i'm going to talk about
plastic alternatives i'm going to talk
about biodegradable containers & mulches
and you will see that there are some
connections between the marker garden
and these alternatives to to plastics
and I'll try to highlight those for you
to kind of make sure that you see that
there's some continuity in my talk so
the marker garden like I said before the
organic farm was started in nineteen
ninety
and this kind of coincides with the
final rule that came out in 2002 so the
farm was actually transitioning wild
USDA was actually putting out the final
rule in 2002 and so we were trend fully
transitioned in 2003 and that's
important because I'm going to show you
a couple of data points from right after
the transition phase and more currently
about two years ago and I'm going to try
to make some comparisons between those
two years so the original objective was
information on transitioning we actually
wanted to look at what is one of the
best ways to transition I'm not going to
talk about that today the current
objective is to look at the impact of
long-term manure applications on organic
systems and you will see there's some
benefits and some drawbacks to long term
manure applications and then the future
objectives starting next year is going
to be the effect of tillage on soil
quality so we have been building soils
or 15 years and so now we want to kind
of know what it what effect dill achieve
these soils and then the last thing of
course is education and education is key
to what we do at the wp organic form so
this is the market garden it's a
completely randomized design with 32
plots 16 those plots are low input plots
and 16 of those plots are high input
plots the Logan Park plots only get
green manures the high input plots get
reverse and a manure application so
that's the big key to this particular
slide the other thing is that we have a
four year crop rotation and the crop
arcade rotation goes between legumes
solon a seeker Bertie and composite e
families of plants and so we have four
year rotation that means each crop has
four low input plots for high input
plots and if you keep on adding that up
you come up with 32 plots 16 and 16 and
within those 16 there's four that are
solon a c4 cucurbits and so on and so
that's the way this whole system is set
up so what we grow for the legumes we
grow provider beans in a succession
planting we grow coastal romaine lettuce
in the leafy crop or brassica which is
not i know it's another so so in
Nebraska we actually have and I'm meant
to say leafy crops have coastal romaine
lettuce and then for the Cure bits we
have done giant zucchini and for the
saloon AC we have both tomato and
peppers in those plots this is the way
that the actual experiment is structured
so you have high input you have compost
or which was basically aged nor the
manure that we use has gone through an
aging process but is not organically
certified compost so when we apply this
material we treat it as if it is
excellen or and I'll show you some more
information on that to show you what
kind of the properties and
characteristics are of this manure but
you we apply about 10 tons per acre of
this manure in the high input plot
nothing in the low input plots in winter
we have established a rive veg cover
crop in both systems in the summer if
the if we're done with a crop we either
put in buckwheat or sometimes also some
other cover crops just to hold over
those plots and one thing that's really
important here is that every other year
when we grow solanaceae will grow curb
its we apply a hey mulch to those plots
and that hate mulch actually gets
incorporated into the soil so the low
input plots get Greek they get cover
crops but they can all they also get
every other year they get a mulch that
is filled in so that becomes part of the
nutrients that actually make it into
those plots the other one the high input
gets an extra 10 tons per acre of manure
now 10 tons per acre is a very very
small amount of
to apply it's basically just a little
dusting or coating it is a very small
amount the reason I mentioned that is
because you will see some of the big
impacts over a period of 15 years so
this is the actual compost or H manure
analysis and what I want to draw your
attention to is that it's got a fairly
high pH and that's because it actually
comes from a very and there's some
calcium that actually made it into this
compost or this aged manure and also
want you to note the fairly high levels
of phosphorus and so those are also key
to what I'm going to show you next so
what I'm showing you here is 2004
immediately after transition and I'm
also showing you two 2014 which is the
last year that I have analyzed data for
what I want you to note is right here
the phosphorus levels in the low input
plot have remained about the same and
the key to that is we basically we've
been removing vegetable matter but we've
been reapplying the hay so some of that
is completely basically balance things
out when it comes to phosphorus when we
are looking at 2014 one thing that I
want you to note is the huge difference
in phosphorus levels between 2004 and
2014 we get huge increases in phosphorus
and that is only logical because we've
been applying manure for the last 15
years now you may say why are you keep
on flying a manure over and over and
over again even though you have plenty
of phosphorus well we were doing this
experiment in conjunction with another
long-term experiment that actually had a
seven year rotation and agronomic crops
and we wanted to go get through at least
two of those rotations before we
switched up this experiment and so
that's why we get to these very very
high levels of phosphorus that really
you don't need or you probably don't
even want in these systems but it was
just basically part of the experimental
design
the other thing that I want you to note
is whoops sorry the other sorry the
other thing I want you to note is the
very high levels of calcium and that's
because that that aged manure came in
with quite a bit of calcium we also
occasionally limed the plots especially
the low input plots to make sure that
the ph was about the same as the high
input plots so this is a little bit more
information on the actual yields that we
received off of those plots so what this
is showing is we have the low input we
have pounds per acre and a high input
pounds per acre for 2014 we did the same
thing for 2004 but what we noticed is
that when you combine multiple years
together we can't really see very many
difference between low and high input
plots so what we did is we normalize the
data to percent of an average yield for
that year and that allowed us then to
combine the two years the 2004 and the
2014 together and do statistical
analysis on those combined years now
there is plenty of other data but I'm
just showing you for these two years and
so the result of all of this is
basically that for the high input plots
you can get about twenty to twenty-five
percent higher yields when you apply ten
tons per acre of this h 2 ER that that's
just what we came up with and you see
that kind of consistently except maybe
for tomatoes where we didn't see those
same differences but what that does is
if you take that amount of yield and you
turn it into a monetary value and
basically what we did is we can get
let's say two dollars for green beans if
we have a yield that is about 5,000 some
pounds more per acre you multiply that
by the amount that you can get for the
beans let's say two dollars per pound
you come up with a number that indicates
what that compost is actually worth to
you so you can actually
that this compost is 10 tons of dairy
manure is worth or is of a lot of value
especially to a marker garden type of
setting where you're going to do retail
up selling and so this basically shows
you that getting compost off farm you
can actually get that at very high a
cost and still come out ahead when
you're applying this compost now the
main thing that I want you to remember
of all of this is that we can still get
good yields in the low input plots so if
you just use cover crops and hey mulches
we get good yields we add in manure we
get about twenty percent higher yield
what that means is that twenty percent
that twenty percent higher yield you can
actually make a lot of money and you can
actually afford to apply more manure
however there are some drawbacks to
applying manure over and over and over
again and so one of the one of those
drawbacks is those high phosphorus
stocks but there are also some key
benefits to applying that manure over 15
years and one of the things that you
will see here is that in high input
plots after about five years of applying
four years of applying does their manure
we actually increased the level of soil
organic matter to six point four percent
which is pretty high we also saw that if
you keep on doing this after about 15
years of application of this H newer we
saw that you can actually increase the
organic matter content of the soil to
about eight point seven percent which is
really high and actually we can see
differences just by looking at the soil
when it's rain so you can actually see
differences in in darkness of these
soils and that's by applying basically
150 tons over 15 years of manures now
that sounds like a lot but if you only
do that every
we're very small amounts that is a very
very small amount to apply every year
the other benefit we saw besides
increased in that soil organic matter is
we also saw that the bulk density of the
soil decreased and so that's what you
see right here the bulk density is
basically inversely related to the soil
organic matter as you have more organic
matter the soul become is weighs less
per volume and so that's what you see
here but what I want to draw your
attention to is that those differences
if you see those error bars they's those
differences did not show up until about
ten years after we started the
experiment and that's because we just
have a lot of variability in those plots
so my suggestion here is that this is
related or this is important when we're
talking about long-term studies this is
something that you would have never seen
if you would have stopped this study
after about five or six years and so
these are some of the reasons that I
think that we should actually have
long-term studies because some of these
differences don't show up until much
later so to recap this section of my
talk agreement ors together with a Milch
incorporation can maintain yields about
eighty percent of those when you
actually apply the manure so that's
important despite improvements in yield
soil organic matter and bulk density
continuous application of relatively low
levels of manure can lead to excessive
levels of potassium and phosphorus and
of course that's a bad thing so it's a
mixed bag so basically what we want to
do next with these plots is we want the
reverse two treatments so we want to
take the high input plots and start
treating them as low input plots trying
to draw down the phosphorus and
potassium levels and we want to take
blue input plots and start applying
composted or aged manure but then
stopped at a normal level of topacio and
phosphorus and try to manage those
particular plots only with cream
universe and it
occasional addition of regular manures
so next I'm going to talk a little bit
about alternatives to plastics and I
want you to remember that I talked about
hey and hey mulches and that will come
up here in a little bit again and so I
just want to make sure that you you're
on board with me on this one so we're
going to talk about alternative
containers so we I was part of a
specialty crops research initiative
project where we studied ten different
by the big gradable containers that were
either on the market or were poised to
be on the market in the United States
and so we actually tested these ten
different containers regular control
plastic a bioplastic choir this is a
common or our compost pot this is a wood
pulp this is what's called a bio sleeve
is made out of also a biodegradable
plastic this is rice hull both slotted
and solid rice hull this is made with
rice hulls and basically a wax and it's
pressed together we have a straw pot
that's made with rice straw and then we
also have a peak pot and so those are
the different pots that were used in
this study so one thing that I want to
show you is that there were actual
differences in growth when we grew
plants in these bio pots or these
alternative containers one big
difference that we saw is right here
that the control actually had slightly
lower levels of growth than some of
these bio pots and I'll get in a minute
here but why that could be but really
what I want you to note is that the
straw pot and the sleeve had some of the
highest biomass production in these
different pots one of the things that
people sometimes say well that could be
because these pots had different volumes
you have different values of media and
so that's why you might get different
levels of growth well when we first
started this experiment we actually
measured the amount of media we
each pot so all of the plants were
growing in the same volume of media so
even if the pot was a little bit taller
you have the same amount of actual media
in it what we think is going on here is
this straw pot and this sleeve this
sleeve does not have a bottom and what I
think is going on here is additional
area a shin so these drain better the
same thing with the straw pot it is very
very open to the air and so the media
dries out much more quickly and I think
this warrants some more investigation
because even for plastic pots if that's
the case maybe there should be more
holes in a plastic park I'm not saying
if that's true or not but if that's the
case you could actually minimize the
amount of plastic you actually put in a
pot and still get good or better
production and so that's something that
I think came out of this research is
that there's a possibility that maybe
aeration is really key to increase
biomass by the way the crop we grew
right here is New Guinean patients so
this is a flora culture crop and this
was all done in the greenhouse the next
thing that I want to show you is we
check for pH differences within these
different parts of media we use a pore
through method and the result of that
was that the dairy manure which you
would expect to have a higher pH
actually had a higher pH throughout the
study so these are averages over the
whole study so these are pH averages
over the whole study and we noticed that
the dairy manure actually had higher pH
now you could expect that because if you
use the pore through method you're
actually going to leach some of that
compost the dairy manure that makes up
that pot into your leachate so that's
probably why we have a slightly higher
pH in those pots but it's also probably
why we have a slightly lower pH in peat
pots again you rinse it your bleach it
through the pot it's going to make a
difference so if this really makes a
difference or an impact on the axle
growth we doubt that it's probably more
an artifact of actually how we measured
ec mph the next thing that I want you to
know is that these pots have different
ability to hold up during production and
so what we did is we took containers
after we were done with production we
emptied them and we actually measured
how much force it will take to penetrate
the side of the pot to see how well they
disintegrate or how well they hold up
during production the result of this not
not surprising is that plastic pots hold
up better than most other alternative
pots and what we also see is that the
dairy manure the cow pot and this jiffy
pot or the peat pot they disintegrate
the most after about six weeks of
production when you try to lift up these
pots they've basically fall apart most
of these studies were done in shuttle
trace and so these pots were held
together pretty well during production
but after production if you try to lift
them up they do tear apart next thing
again we're looking at the cow pot and
the jiffy pot which by the way our brand
names but this is a compost of the air
manure and again a peat pot what we
noticed is that we got more algebra DH
on those pots than any of the other pots
in the study now the only one the only
other one is the wood fiber apart and I
want to draw your attention to some
things first of all I want you to notice
the idea that this drop pod has more
aeration because it's cross-linked straw
and it's got lots of openings the
slaughter rice hull has slots so it has
more aeration better drainage and this
biodegradable pot has better drainage
because it does not have a bottom I also
want you to focus in on the idea that
these two pots now have come up twice
with some cautionary notes and that will
get into how I actually want to
try to wrap this up so the other thing
that we did is we looked at how easily
can these pots actually be D nested how
easily can they be used in a production
line where you actually are trying to
take the pots apart and what we noticed
is that some of these pots the rice hull
pots right down here they are a lot
easier to remove out of a stack than for
example this jiffy pot and even the
control plastic pot so really what what
I want to focus in on is that these two
pots actually are very easily very
easily handled the other thing I want
you to think about is that this surface
is very rough and that makes these pots
stick together and so it makes it much
more difficult to actually handle these
pots in production settings let's switch
gears we're going to switch gears now we
have had the information about the
biopods in greenhouse production now I'm
going to move on how do these pots
behave when they're planted in the
actual field so two parts that we didn't
plant directly in the field or this
bioplastic one and this rice whole part
because they are actually supposed to be
removed there are compiled compostable
but they are not supposed to be
plantable so in this study we only use
plants that can actually be planted in
the landscape and so that's why there's
a cross over these two that are
basically not part of the study the big
thing that i want you to see here is
really there's nothing to see that's
basically the result of all of this
basically all of these plants if you
plant them together with their pot into
the field you compare it to a pot
plastic pot that has been removed and
the plant planted in the field you get
the same biomass production over a
season so really once they go in the
ground they grow just as well doesn't
matter
which kind of pot you're talking about
this is pot decomposition at the end of
the season so at the end of the season I
had my graduate student dig up all these
pots take all the little pieces of
BioPod she could still find and feed it
through a leaf area meter and so she
looked at how much of that pot was still
there in in the actual field or opposite
how much was still left over and you'll
notice that the manure pot and even less
so that the peak park but the rice whole
pot they have very little decomposition
so the rice hull has very little
decomposition the manure pod has a lot
of decomposition and again thats related
to the greenhouse study where I actually
talked about the idea that these pots
they fall apart after about six to eight
weeks of production so to recap all of
this and I know I'm going to run out of
time and I'm going to try to run through
this a little bit more quickly to kind
of really emphasize the main points of
all of this is that all of these pots
have pros and cons associated with them
so which one should you use well it all
depends on what you want so it all
depends on what you're ultimately
looking for if you're looking for a pot
that holds up well during mechanized
production you would gravitate towards a
plastic or even a rice hull pot because
they can easily be nested if you are
looking for a retail setting you may
want to stay away from a jiffy or a peak
or the peat or the dairy manure pot
because it has a lot of algae growing on
it and it's unsightly so it all depends
on ultimately what you want to do with
these pots where do you want to go with
these pots the other thing that I think
is important just the same we have
controlled release fertilizers that are
used in horticulture I think we should
have something that is akin to
controlled release pots and basically we
should basically market these pots based
on how long they hold up in the
greenhouse
and so I can envision a pot that would
be a six-week pot versus a three-month
puff pot and they would be different
materials and structured differently so
that you know what you're growing and
you know how long that pot is supposed
to hold out and plastic still rules for
the main reason that is just easy to use
it's got a lot of attributes that really
work well for the next thing I want to
talk about is mulches we did some
studies and what this picture is showing
is a wool mulch so I told you before
that we have a holistic approach to our
organic farm so we're trying to use
on-farm resources as mulches and so in
this study where we looked at different
mulches we thought what does the farm
have to offer that we can use as mulches
well we're great we we are raising sheep
so we have to share these sheep every
every spring that wool does not make
much money that there's just not a lot
of money in wool so we actually thought
we could use it as a mulch the same
thing with hey the farm generates hey
for the sheep in the wintertime so what
did we do we start using hey mulch and
then the last one is leaf litter we have
wood lots that are part of our organic
farm and so we collected leaf litter we
set up an experiment again it's a
randomized design we had seven different
treatments two were plastic basically
plastic mulch we had that in two areas
at them by 20 and a 20 by 20 area the
main reason for that is we wanted to
know if in the middle of those plots if
we still got enough moisture to actually
grow a pepper and so that's why we had
these do different size of plastic mulch
we also used hey wasteful leaf litter
and then hand weeding and no weeding at
all really the result of all of this is
marketable yields in plastic are high
but we can get comparable yields with
hey mulch so that's what this is showing
is basically
that hey mulch gives you comparable
yields to plastic mulches the
interesting thing about this is that
this by the way I want you to note that
the it's 67 to 76 degrees on this axis
just to show the differences a little
bit more clearly but clearly plastic is
going to have higher temperatures
whereas hey had much lower temperatures
and that is just the result of inherent
result of those materials and then the
last thing that I want to show you is
that the moisture content under plastic
was much lower than underhay and even
wool and this wool is something that
we've seen over and over again is that
we see much higher soil moisture under
rule than we see in any other mulch and
this is not just in this study we have
done some other work that we show the
same thing now there are some problems
with wool but really basically what I
want to say is that I'm farm resources
can substitute for plastic mulch is
specifically Hey and he has the
additional benefit remember back to when
I first started to talk you can use it
as a mulch but you can also use it for
fertility so you have a double kind of
thing that you can get out of hey you
can use it as something that is actually
incorporated in the soil we can also use
it as a mulch and wool has a potential
as a perennial mulch because one of the
things it does not do is degrade very
easily at the end of the season you have
us almost as much wool left as you do in
the beginning of the season and it's
really really thick and so I think it
has potential for actually a perennial
mulch because it just doesn't degrade
very rapidly it takes many many years
and we actually have to clear it off the
plots before we till it because it's it
gets bound up in the tiller again
Plastics come out ahead mostly because
of the price if you think about hey
applying about five tons of hay per acre
of vegetable production we're talking
about a lot of hay hay that can be sold
or use this animal feed so we're talking
about a very high cost again there's
some drawbacks
she aided with some of these
alternatives some other work that I've
done at the organic farm includes some
work with green beans and control of
mexican bean beal with a biological
called video bius 50 Lauda's i've done
some work on solarization in west
virginia which actually works which is
kind of neat we've done some work with
water inclusion in season extension and
we've also done some work on transplant
production specifically transporting
production for organic production
alright this ultra I'm sorry if I'm
going over a little bit i'll try to okay
all right i'm just want to make sure
that if people have believed that i'm
done so so the other thing is the
organic farm and Education and over the
years we've had about 40 interns that
have interned at the farm and learned
about organic production techniques we
just recently got a retired professor
retired faculty member donate 25
thousand dollars a year for an
internship program and so we now have
about six or seven interns every year
that can help us out with the research a
lot of the research that I've shown you
was done on kind of a shoestring budget
and a lot of it was done with
undergraduate researchers and that's one
of the I guess there's a benefit to that
to the student but for me it's sometimes
difficult to find the consistency in
data collection and so forth but we have
two majors that link up with the organic
form very closely horticulture and
agriculture and so we do have these two
majors we do have the organic farm
internship program and we run of winter
CSA and a summer CSA and it's a pretty
small CSA but it still generates about
eight thousand dollars for the farm the
winter CSA in the summer CSAR 20 weeks
csa's we asked for about 20-25 dollars a
week so we generate about eight to ten
thousand dollars we also started looking
into wholesale production because we've
so far we've really the farm is focused
very much on local production local
markets si si and so forth we wanted to
venture out into something that is a
little bit more wholesale and so we've
contracted with a company in Virginia
Appalachian harvest to take any
butternut squash that we produce on the
farm that meets their standards and as
part of that effort we actually have to
get gap certification and we are going
to actually go through the process of
gap certification now and the really
neat thing about that is is students
actually can be involved in the organic
certification process but now also in
the gap certification process which is
really important if you're going to do
any production that you're trying to
sell wholesale because most suppliers
most aggregators will actually require
that your gap certified future
directions for the work at wvu first of
all tillage really what I want to look
at is no-till or low till vegetable
production and i want to compare that to
conventional tillage and see how these
soils that we've built up over the years
with this high soil organic matter this
low bulk density how are those soils
going to behave under different tillage
systems so that's where we're going to
go with that work so it's going to
continue that long term at work the
other thing that I want to look at is
mulch is a little bit more specifically
these on-farm resources and how we can
best use them and we definitely want to
expand the CSA and entrepreneurship
options and the university is really
keen on the idea to get students exposed
to entrepreneurship so one of the key
pillars of wvu is prosperity and so the
university is really pushing the idea of
creating entrepreneurs on campus that
can go back to their communities and
actually start businesses and so we will
definitely emphasize this and then the
last thing that I think we don't do
enough is that
measure the impact of educational
methods so what does what is the impact
of the CSA's of these student clubs on
the learning and teaching at a
university so keys to undergraduate
education at WVU goes anywhere from
undergrad research which by the way
stretch is limited funding so I can
oftentimes find students they get
interested and excited about a project
and I can get them for credit to help me
out with my research so that's one way
that I stretch my very very limited
funding plus the students gets exposure
to research and oftentimes they go on to
graduate school either a double view or
somewhere else independent studies all
not all of the projects students do our
research projects I try to encourage
projects beyond just research projects
more demonstration or just to teach them
certain techniques and that's something
that we do independent studies we grow
seven or eight and they're poinsettias
every fall we grow a bunch of hanging
baskets in the spring and students
actually get exposure to some of those
some of those things that way and then
clubs clubs can be a key to education
it's a great way to instill a sense of
entrepreneurship because clubs are often
times in fundraising mode if they want
to travel somewhere and so it's a great
way to kind of combine these two
together last one is internships of
internships both on the farm to wvu
organic farm but also outside of the
farm are key to a really good
undergraduate education I have a couple
more minutes what I want to do is I want
to introduce a few of my colleagues so
if there is any interest beyond what
I've talked about in the audience I just
want to focus you in on what some of the
other people are doing at W so gang moku
right up here he's a new faculty member
he's an assistant professor has been
with us for about a year he's working on
glucosinolates mostly broccoli
but also some other plants and looking
at nutraceuticals michael guten ssin
right here he's also new have been hired
within the last year and a half he is
very interested in plant biochemistry
specifically terpenoid biosynthesis we
have Nicole waterland who's interested
in greenhouse production does work with
LEDs also has switched over some of our
ornamental work into vegetable
production in greenhouses David Davis
comes to us by way of Virginia Tech and
he does mostly teaching Louis jet down
here he is high tunnels and he does a
lot of work with hide tunnels in West
Virginia Jim Watson right here he
actually takes care of the sheep and the
economic crops on the organic farm and
there's of course many many others that
have other additional roles at the
organic farm so to finish up the
take-home messages the things that I
really would like you to go home with
today are manure applications have clear
benefits and this is not rocket science
this is something that you could have
probably guessed even without doing this
research but what I would like to note
is that building soils can also lead to
excessive nutrients and so the idea is
that you really have to combine these
manure and compost applications together
with cover crops to really come up with
a good mix for vegetable production
plastics are popular for a reason and
the alternatives have very high
standards to match if nothing else costs
it is just very very cheap to lay down a
layer of plastic and it is just much
more expensive to use other alternatives
so the other thing that I'd like you to
remember is that some of these changes
that we see not just in soil organic
matter but also in bulk density are very
very slow to materialize and so long
term studies are very very important to
what we do in horticulture and like I
said before more is not better when
building soils and oftentimes we still
have growers that will not necessarily
test their soil and so this is again
basically saying soil tests are key to
good fertility management and then
plastics in many cases still rule for
good reason and then the last thing that
I want to mention is these other class
experiences other class experiences are
to me key to a good education and I
think a lot of Education happens outside
of the classroom not necessarily inside
of the classroom and so internships
clubs any kind of independent study even
though that could be considered a class
is additional exposure to creativity
that I think is very important to foster
so with that I'm going to stop right
here that's my talk I'll entertain
questions if you haven't
we're a threshold for the DMK in the
soil that creates an adverse effect on
healed not not breed we were not
reaching the high enough salt levels to
affect yield but what we are doing is
basically those very high potassium is
not as big of an issue that phosphorus
can actually become a blue team known so
you know it could be a point source
pollution and so those levels that i
showed you after 15 years are three
times as high as would normally be good
for production so their way with higher
than so the part of developing our
holistic organic farm is also selecting
plan ideo types that are suited
system from carries with the organ farm
does any variety evaluations or any
direct breeding for organic defects so
if there's any breeding efforts at the
farm no we do not we we have one
graduate student who's doing a little
bit of greening work with quinoa but
that's about the extent of any kind of
reading that we do and I I definitely
have to say that that is really
important the idea that you want to use
varieties that are basically developed
with organic systems in mind we just
started using certain of these varieties
and just for consistency's sake have
stuck through a lot of these varieties
but for example we do use a local
variety West Virginia 63 that was
developed at the University that has
some leibach light and early blight
resistance so you do try that we just
have not made any kind of major inroads
into any kind of reading
no and so Russian was the question was
do we use any irrigation on these plots
so for the long-term study we do not
consistently use irrigation and that's
my best way of describing some years we
do a better job than other years and it
all depends again because we have
undergraduate students that help us out
in some years we can just do a better
job of that pest control
the potassium for sure the phosphorus is
probably found so that probably cannot
necessarily be at least as easily as the
potassium and there could be an argument
be made or that very high level of
phosphorus if you tie that together with
organic matter that it is not as much of
a pollutant as if it was just in a more
mineral soil anyway I'm not going to
necessarily make that case but maybe
maybe one more
well I mean equal go ahead and we'll go
to communities ok so I'm sorry there's a
little bit more about the romantic part
of the structure the management is it a
teaching far more research farm or a
student forum and then also does the
organic one help you recruit more
students are even attracting new
students that wouldn't normally be
interested in agriculture so the farm is
teaching an education but a lot of
sorcerer matter no we do not we have a
farm worker that does the movie and all
the other stuff is run by me and dr.
Coates and we manage the interns we
managed everything that happens at that
farm it really we try to generate some
funds to go back into that internship so
we do run that csa we do sell a little
bit to farmers markets we've been really
reluctant to sell farmers markets
because we oftentimes get complaints
that we compete with local producers and
that's something that I haven't heard
here as I've been talking to people that
we do get that that's a little bit issue
for us so what was the other partner
come in so does our students are you
tracking
students because of the organic Connor
man does it yes yes we do use it as a
recruiting tool and a great ecology
that's the major that this is closely
tied to even though a lot of the speeds
that in turn are also a vertical she's
pleased when we bring students on campus
this is something that is definitely
highlighted as something that we have on
hand fair so yes it's definitely used in
the career efforts mostly due to Edgar
ecology and the greenhouse is more used
to to reprove horticulture students so
before we quickly go to Geneva I do
believe that there is a lunch for
graduate students starting a very soon
3 360 any graduate students are rolling
quickly from Geneva then all I was
surprised at all most gracious honest
opinion so I wonder you can see little
bit to the nitrogen budget going forward
are you looking at more of the nitrogen
in the flux themselves starting
elsewhere on the farm the credit balance
out there yeah so the big thing is going
to be we need to get a better handle on
how much nitrogen is in that hay and
that would be our first that's
definitely the way we would grow that
come across green manures measure how
much nitrogen we're fixing there and
then fill in with mostly the a as an
additional level of nitrogen and then
only as a last resort if we need
basically phosphorus I go to the manures
so that that would be kind of the level
and we would try to meet what are
basically kind of standard you know
levels of nitrogen that you would want
to fly to vegetables now the problem
that we sometimes have is how much of
that nitrogen
is actually available to that crop
versus how much is held over and that's
a whole other research question but I
think we would try to manage mostly most
of it by cover crops like leggings great
quote Sam thanks very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu